this morning we continue our kindness
101 series with Steve Hartman sharing
stories built around kindness and
character and the people who have
mastered those qualities today's lesson
is reverence in honor of Veterans Day
coming up this Friday Steve and his kids
show us why one man traveled 1200 miles
to pay respects to a Texas boys Fallen
Hero
good morning this is my daughter Meryl
hi everyone today's class is about
reverence for definition let's go over
to my brother Emma at the dictionary
desk Emmett good morning Merle when you
show someone reverence you're treating
them with profound respect almost like
awe right and since Veterans Day is
coming up today we're going to focus on
reverence for the military
Merrell for the longest time you could
only fall asleep if your mom or I were
in the room with you why was that
gave me the knowing that somebody was
watching over me right and adults need
that too we need someone to help us
sleep at night and that's why a lot of
Americans have great reverence for our
military Guardians and their families
and people show that reverence in some
remarkable ways as you'll see in this
story pulled from our kindness 101
archive filed under reverence
whoa even in Texas a horse only gets you
so far which is why 15 year old Justin
Rozier has been thinking lately about a
car specifically he told his mom Jessica
he would love to have a car that his dad
once owned whoa I mean it could have
been a 1974 Dodge Astro I didn't know if
that's a car but it could have been
anything and he would have said yes why
I know that he wishes his dad was here
in 2003 Justin's dad Army first
lieutenant Jonathan Rosier died in Iraq
Justin was nine months old
today he cherishes anything that used to
belong to his dad which is why he
thought it would be so cool to have his
car I don't know like just knowing that
that he had it it's a whole lot
different than just any other thing
unfortunately after John died Jessica
had to sell the car a 99 Toyota Celica
convertible like this one finding it
again would be nearly impossible but
Jessica said she had to at least try I
feel like this is something that would
would connect him
so she turned to Facebook posted the old
VIN number with a note asking for help
and somehow that message made it all the
way to Pleasant Grove Utah where local
residents not only found the car we
decided you know let's let's see if we
can buy the car this is Kyle fox now I'm
not saying he's a saint but to serve and
um and that butterfly stayed there for
half an hour no I don't even know where
I was in that anyway Kyle who runs a
non-profit called follow the flag got
donations to purchase the car and then
assembled a team of volunteer mechanics
to fix it like new all of this
unbeknownst to Justin
until this very moment
Kyle drove the car from Utah to surprise
Justin for his 15th birthday Garcia I
can't tell you what this meant to Justin
I mean I really can't
he tried to explain it to me but when he
opened his mouth
no words fell out
It's A Link to the Past for him it's a
big thing for me too
I never got to see him come home so that
just one moment right there was I think
I needed that
obviously this was never about a car
this was about finding a way to push
past what you can't forget and somehow
remember
what you never knew I'm so glad we could
do this for you
grateful American and Butterfly magnet
Kyle Fox joins us now hello Kyle hey
how's it going thanks for having me
why do you think
of a reverence
to live in this land of Freedom somebody
sacrificed to the extent of signing
their life away and so to just be free
in America I recognize the the real
truth of what it took to get me there
what other things have you done to honor
veterans
a friend of mine I asked if you'd help
me hang a big
we kind of shower curtained a flag out
there on July 3rd
how big was this flag quarter acre 400
pounds five foot Stars wow were you ever
in the military yourself I was not but
um we all have ways that we can serve
and this has become mine
thank you so much thanks for talking to
us and thanks for all you've done thank
you very much guys thank you
Veterans Day is Friday obviously we
don't expect people to go out and donate
a car to show their gratitude but a
little note might be nice
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
so the kindness didn't stop in 2017 when
Steve's story first aired the engine of
Justin's car actually broke down in 2020
but a group of mechanics stepped up and
fixed it for him free of charge Dixon
Automotive in Hondo Texas did the labor
in the local NAPA store donated the
parts Steve reports that Justin is now a
sophomore at Houston Community College
how about that Steve Hartman in the
family does it again yes how about Dixon
Automotive and you know that Justin what
that means to you to have a car that
your dad actually drove you can see that
your dad had touched that wheel and sat
on that seat that was and also be
touching because of what your dad
dedicated his life to all these people
down the line down the line down the
line dedicated all their time and love
so that they could deliver this to you
it meant what your father did in his
life had meaning to all of these people
you've never met so many heroes in that
story you too Kyle I love that follow
the flag yes it's fitting as we are here
at midterms
flag never gets old to me never